[Applaus]
[Musik]
die frau die gerade auf dem bildschirm
sieht es mayas hondo die proeuropäische
präsidentin von moldawien einem jener
länder die den krieg zwischen russland
und der ukraine in höchster anspannung
und alarmbereitschaft verfolgen und nein
wir übertreiben nicht die präsidentin
selbst bezeichnet die aktuelle situation
als die gefährlichste zeit in der
geschichte des landes nur eine woche
nachdem russland einen brutalen
angriffskrieg gegen die ukraine
gestartet hat hat die republik moldau
auf rumänisch moldova genannt einen
antrag auf beitritt zur europäischen
union gestellt werden wunders natürlich
wird dieser prozess weder einfach sein
noch schnell vonstattengeht reden hier
über ein land das mit der ukraine um den
titel des ärmsten landes in europa
konkurriert und dass außerdem ernsthafte
politische probleme hat angefangen bei
der tatsache dass der staat noch nicht
einmal über die grundlegende territorial
und grenzkontrolle im eigenen land
verliebt wir sind der schwächste nachbar
der ukraine wir sind das land das am
meisten davon betroffen ist und wissen
das land das die wenigsten ressourcen
hat um mit der situation und den folgen
des krieges fertig zu werden nico
popescu außenminister der republik
moldau warum sagt die moldawische
präsidentin dass dies eine der
gefährlichsten zeiten in der geschichte
des landes ist was genau könnte es
solche schlagzeilen erklärt
vierundzwanzigster april der
regierungsstellen der usa und der
ukraine waren vor hoher
wahrscheinlichkeit einer invasion putins
in moldawien bedeutet dies dass nicht
das was wir in der ukraine erleben in
moldawien wiederholen könnte findet
deutschland bald eine fortsetzung des
russischen eroberungskriege stadt nun
viele von euch werden sich vielleicht
fragen warum wir überhaupt diesen
kleinen land ein ganzes video widmen
aber passt auf denn wir haben es hier
mit so etwas wie einem versteckten aber
mächtigen joker in putins ärmel zu tun
einem land mit einer hochgradig
interessanten vergangenheit einer noch
exklusiveren gegenwart und eine verdammt
spannenden zukunft welche auch die
zukunft der ukraine russlands und
europas entscheidend beeinflussen könnte
also schnallt euch an heute wird es
ziemlich bizarr zu gehen aber auch umso
aufschlussreicher
eine von russland angeheizt der spaltung
[Musik]
moldawien war nix zweitkleinste republik
der ehemaligen sowjetunion als die
sowjetunion zusammenbrach und moldawien
seine unabhängigkeit erklärt
unterstützte russland eine
separatistische rebellion in
transnistrien wodurch eine neue quasi
republik entstand
sowie der fluss nicht bei dem carina in
zwei hälften teilt der läster die
republik moldau in zwei ethnisch
sprachlich unterschiedliche regionen
während westlich des nächster
mehrheitlich ethnische rumänen
sprechende moldawier erleben wird
transnistrien von einer eindeutigen
slawischen mehrheit dominiert die
russische oder ukrainische sprache
spricht
tatsache ist dass er den bruch zwischen
diesen beiden regionen in der so
genannten pigs ocean moldauischen
republik besser bekannt als
transnistrien einem der bizarrsten nicht
anerkannten staaten der welt für
russische soldaten etwa 1700 an der zahl
stationiert sind dieser schmalen
landstreifen zwischen moldawien und der
ukraine mit angeblich von 500.000
einwohnern von denen man annimmt dass
nur mehr als 200.000 tatsächlich dort
leben und wird vom prorussischen
separatisten regiert und weitgehend von
moskau aus alimentiert moskau sollte
nicht nur für sicherheit sondern auch
für kostenloses erdgas und
rentenzuschüsse
[Musik]
ein spaziergang durch die straßen von
tiraspol der hauptstadt rassismus ist
wie eine zeitreise und 40 jahre zurück
in eine art und mit einem hauch
raubtierkapitalismus wir sprechen von
einem ort an dem die einwohner unter
einem sperrfeuer aus hof schoppmann das
leben der transnistrien konflikt stellt
eigentlich ein unglaubliches
historisches kuriosum dar eine
geschichte wie sie verrückter nicht sein
könnte weist nämlich im august 1991 in
moskau alte kommunistische hardliner und
kgb schergen gegen den damaligen
präsidenten der sowjetunion michail
gorbatschow putschten und versuchten das
ganze land unter ihre kontrolle zu
bekommen erklärte man in chisinau die
unabhängigkeit von moskau und der
putschisten regierung und forderte den
abzug aller sowjetischen truppen im
ostteil entrust riehen stieß dies jedoch
auf widerstand man gründete dort sogar
einen neuen obersten sowjet der die
ziele der putschisten in moskau
unterstützte doch mit dem scheitern des
august putsches war die auflösung des
sowjetunion faktisch besiegelt weswegen
man wiederum in transnistrien die
unabhängigkeit aus rief sowohl von
moldau als auch von moskau wo er nun
wieder gorbatschow und jetzt gehen die
macht innehatten der interessenkonflikt
zwischen moskau und genau der mit der
unabhängigkeitserklärung moskaus zwar zu
einem ende gekommen schien wurde jetzt
durch den konflikt mit tiraspol erneuert
und ausgerechnet das reformierte
postsowjetischen moskau aus nun
regelmäßig dieses feuer durch direkte
militärische für tiraspol und die
entsendung von besatzungstruppen so
wurde an diesem ort quasi die
sowjetunion lange nachdem sie überall
schon längst untergegangen war in einem
zustand der desintegration wie in einer
zeitschleife eingefroren transnistrien
ist sozusagen der ereignishorizont des
russischen schwarzen lochs und
tatsächlich ist es so dass nicht nur auf
der trasse istrischen flagge noch immer
hammer und sichel prangen nein das
kleine splitter land wird nämlich noch
immer von den gleichen alten kgb
seilschaften beherrscht so wird die
wirtschaft transnistrien seit den 90er
jahren von einem einzigen unternehmen
monopolisiert einem unternehmen das
punkt ehemaligen kgb-agenten viktor bout
schauen mit hilfe einiger sein der
arbeiter gegründet wurde und dem heute
alles gehört und diese illustre firma
trägt auch noch einen sehr bezeichnenden
namen sheriff tja wenn die coen brüder
und polster hoffen gemeinsam einen film
über das erste land der welt gedreht
hätten wäre ihnen sicher auch nichts
besseres eingefallen als das real
existierende
transnistrien übrigen ist wenn ich sage
dass dem sheriff alles im land gehört
dann meine ich wirklich absolut alles
von der landesweiten supermarktkette
über den gleichnamigen champions league
fußballvereinen sporthallen
telekommunikationsunternehmen mitsamt
eigene mobilfunknetz tankstellen tabak
und spirituosen fabriken bäckereien ein
verlagshaus eine baugesellschaft einst
an die sender und natürlich äußerst
lukrative polit business sheriff
kontrolliert sogar transnistriens
regierungspartei die sich erneuerung
nicht und ganz 29 133 sitze in obersten
sowjet innehat
aber achtung traditionell ist kein
kommunistisches land sondern ein land im
vollbesitz eine oligarchen clique die
alles im leben der transnistrien
kontrolliert und wie ihr euch sicher
leicht vorstellen könnt haben menschen
ohne gute connections zu dieser kleinen
elite rein gar keine chance ist so
irgendwas in diesen kleinen splitter
land zu bringen aber lassen sie uns
nicht ablenken nach dem antrag
moldawiens auf eu-mitgliedschaft am
dritten märz hat transnistrien erneute
anerkennung seiner vollen 100 fähigkeit
gefordert und das ist noch nicht alles
[Musik]
denn darauf im monat am 22 april
erklärte der russische generalstab das
ist moskaus tier seit die gesamte
klinische küste zu besetzen und so eine
direkte landverbindung nach
transnistrien zu schaffen da die
russischsprachigen menschen in moldawien
unterdrückt würden so weit seine
behauptung und kommt euch das ganze
nicht wie ein kleines déjà vu vor
es ist praktisch derselbe vorwurf den
der kreml schon lange zeit gegen die
ukraine erhebt und wie ihr euch
vorstellen könnt hat das alles in
chisinau alle alarmglocken läuten lassen
denn ganz zufällig gab es nur drei tage
nach diesen wink mit dem zaunpfahl im
transnistrischen ministerium für
staatssicherheit in tiraspol eine
explosion und nur einen tag später
zerstörten zwei weitere explosionen die
antennen des senders kleides ein anderes
kann ich meine des russischen
staatsfonds in transnistrien und wisst
ihr was niemand absolut niemand hat sich
zu diesen anschlägen bekannt was dann
doch einige fragen aufgeworfen hat waren
als ukrainische saboteure die versuchten
russische objekte zu zerstören oder
waren es die russen selbst die mit
operationen unter falscher flagge
versuchten eine militäraktion zu
rechtfertigen
und das wäre nicht das erste mal kein
wunder also dass es neue darlehen
verdammt mit der angst zu tun bekam
zumal ist eines der ersten und
wehrlosesten ländern europas ist die
republik moldau verfügt nur über eine
winzige veraltete und schlecht
ausgerüstete armee dienen nicht einmal
über keine flugzeuge und gerade mal
sechs transporthubschrauber verfügt ihre
panzer sind im grunde antiquitäten die
in einem museum gehören und nicht auf
ein schlachtfeld und obendrein hat das
land kaum 6000 soldaten erschwerend
kommt hinzu dass die republik moldau nie
versucht hat der nato beizutreten
tatsächlich ist das konzept der
neutralität seit 1994 in der verfassung
verankert die bedrohung durch
nato-erweiterung karte konnte moskau
hier also bisher nicht ziehen die frage
ist also was könnte sich russlands sonst
noch einfallen lassen um ein land zu
überfallen das keine bedrohung
darstellen kann besteht wirklich die
gefahr einer eskalation des konflikts
nun durchaus und deswegen nehmen wir das
ganze jetzt mal etwas genauer unter die
lupe
eine gesellschaft am scheideweg
so welches der könnte moskau den
konflikt auf dieses neue land ausweiten
wollen nun der ukrainische präsident
selbst sagte dass die explosionen das
werk moskaus waren aber das muss ja noch
nichts heißen allerdings hatte russland
wie gesagt eine über lange historie von
false flag operationen und häufig sind
diese bezüglich ihres timings und ihre
ausführung eben so plump und
offensichtlich wie diese so wurde in
kassels trainer rein zufällig zur
gleichen zeit eine große zahl von
flugblättern verteilt in denen die
dortigen russen aufgefordert werden
gegen moldawien oder sogar gegen die
ukraine selbst zu den waffen zu greifen
daher bestand nach dem beginn der
russischen invasion in der ukraine eine
der ersten sicherheitsvorkehrung der
ukrainischen armee darin jene brücken
unpassierbar zu machen welche russische
truppen möglicherweise benutzen können
um einen angriff auf und deshalb von
transnistrien aus zu unterstützen
bedenkt bitte das zu den 1500 russischen
soldaten noch die 4500 bis 7500 soldaten
welt transnistrischen armee hinzu kommen
insgesamt also 6000 bis 9000 mann die in
moskau einsetzen könnte umsatzziele zu
erreichen
sowohl in der ukraine als auch in
moldawien selbst russische soldaten und
die transnistrische armee konnten
innerhalb einer stunde in chisinau
einmarschieren allerdings geht es nicht
nur um die hosen die gemeinde kubasta
ein dorf im norden der separatistischen
region beherbergt das größte
munitionsdepot in ganz osteuropa es
könnte sich um etwa 20.000 tonnen
munition aus der zeit handeln welche die
ukraine eventuell neutralisieren oder in
ihren besitz bringen wollen
um euch eine vorstellung davon zu geben
was dort lagern könnte schätze die
akademie der wissenschaften
im jahr 2005 dass eine explosion in
diesem depot wenn eine explosion der
hiroshima atombombe vergleichbar wäre
natürlich reden wir ja schon sehr sehr
alten waffen die vor mehr als 30 jahren
das letzte mal erneuert worden wer weiß
in welchem zustand sich das zeug
befindet aber trotzdem besteht eben
diese möglichkeit und diese durchaus zur
weiteren eskalation des konflikts
beitragen die zukunft moldawiens hängt
davon ab ob die ukrainische armee
durchhält sie kämpfen nicht nur für die
ukraine sondern auch für uns
möglicherweise schon eine groß angelegte
russische invasion moldawiens heute
praktisch undurchführbar zu sein dass
militärische desaster in der ukraine hat
diese möglichkeit wohl komplett richtig
gemacht die frage ist jedoch wie es
gekommen wäre wenn die russen erfolg
gehabt hätten und vor allem heißt dies
dass moldawien nichts mehr zu befürchten
hat nun leider scheint es so dass nicht
von der wahrheit weiter entfernt sein
könnte
denn in diesem fall greift moskau zu
ganz anderen lassen es wird in san luca
2020 mit einer eindeutigen moskau
kritischen und sehr pro-europäischen
botschaft an die macht ihr gegner von
damals und derzeitiger oppositionsführer
ist das genaue gegenteil
egon vorsitzender der sozialistischen
partei ist ein pro russischer und
ausgesprochen anti westliche politiker
denkt der kreml also wirklich über einen
kleinen regime change nach die könntet
ihr versuchen dieses ziel zu erreichen
welche realen bedrohung ist moldawien
ausgesetzt und schauen wir uns mal an
was genau die russen in diesen kleinen
verachten osteuropäischen land erreichen
wollen um diese frage beantworten zu
können
auf dem weg in die europäische union
am 15 november 2020 gewann maria sandow
die wahlen mit einer überwältigenden
mehrheit aus der moldawischen diaspora
erhielt sogar 93 prozent der stimmen die
prorussische fraktion in der
moldawischen republik verlor vorerst
ihre macht das ganze café moskau
überraschend ihr verbündete goldene
schien unglaublich fest im sattel zu
sitzen und über enormen einfluss zu
verfügen er hatte sich praktisch alle
institutionen des landes untertan
gemacht und verfügt über eine stabile
mehrheit im parlament es besteht sogar
verdacht und da dachte ist noch
untertrieben dass er diese enorme
machtkonzentration nutzte um seine
politischen gegner - auszuspionieren und
zu überwachen natürlich illegal und als
ob das noch nicht genug wäre erhielt er
auch noch erhebliche finanzielle und
politische unterstützung aus moskau aber
was mit all diesen massiven mitteln
konnte er keinen erfolg verbuchen
die internen pflege zwischen den
verschiedenen prorussischen fraktionen
und die wachsende unzufriedenheit in der
bevölkerung führten dazu dass die alte
moldawische debatte zwischen eine
orientierung zum westen sind oder eben
in russland ende der 2020er jahre
eindeutig entschieden wurde nämlich in
richtung westen und für eine integration
in die europäische union sandoz haupt
versprechen bei jedoch der kampf gegen
korruption und coop lose oligarchen und
eines ist klar für europa und gegen
korruption dieser cocktail ist natürlich
zu viel für putin viel zu viel das kann
der kreml herrscher nicht so einfach auf
sich sitzen lassen nato hin oder her und
im juli 2021 wurde dieser starke kurs
weg von moskau songs auch noch weiter
verfestigt dass die partei aktion
solidarität von meyers eindruck bei den
parlamentswahlen eine klare absolute
mehrheit erhielt einer sache liege somit
die zuschauer müssen wir uns jedoch klar
sein moldawien ist eigentlich ein echtes
jobs schiphol nicht nur das ist in einem
pro kopf bip von 4500 us-dollar zusammen
mit der ukraine des ernster land europas
ist was ländern wie paraguay guatemala
oder el salvador entspricht nein das
land welches vor 30 jahren noch 4,4
millionen einwohner hatte es bis heute
auch weniger als drei millionen
zusammengeschrumpft und da ist es
abgespaltenen transnistrien mit
eingerechnet mit anderen worten wir
sprechen über ein land das nicht nur ein
riesiges wirtschaftliches desaster
erlebt hat sondern auch eine große
abwanderung der bevölkerung tatsächlich
sind die überweisungen von auslassen
weil dauernd in die heimat praktisch der
wichtigste wirtschaftszweig des landes
sie machten fast 16 prozent der gesamten
moldauischen wirtschaft aus ein gutes
beispiel dafür wie die dinge in diesem
land gelaufen sind war 2014 als die
nachricht von einem bankenskandal die
runde machte und schnell als der raub
des jahrhunderts bekannt wurde in nur
drei tagen wurde und eine milliarde
dollar aus drei moldawischen banken
gestohlen und ausland gewaschen das
entspricht einem achtel der gesamten
volkswirtschaft die operation wurde vom
reichsten oligarchen des landes platini
abo geleitet und von den damaligen
russlandfreundlichen regierung selbst
unterstützt tatsache ist dass meier
sandro aus all diesen gründen die wahlen
2020 gewonnen hat und zwar mit einem
ganz klaren ziel das land zu
modernisieren und von korruption zu
befreien um es auf einen weg in die
europäische union zu bringen und wie ihr
euch vorstellen könnt ist der kreml
darüber überhaupt nicht glücklich
tatsächlich begannen die probleme moskau
schon kurz nach dem amtsantritt der
neuen präsidenten die frage lautet also
was genau kann bleibt mir putin
unternehmen um seinen einfluss in
moldawien zurückzugewinnen aufgepasst
der den change
die frage ist könnte moskau einen
putschversuch wagen um einen
regimewechsel in moldawien zu erzwingen
julia so etwas könnte auf verschiedene
arten erfolgen erstes könnte eine volle
kooperation in transnistrien moskau
einen vorwand liefern um eine kampagne
der militärischen und wirtschaftlichen
bestrafung zu entfesseln hörst ladin
einfluss nutzen denn es hat um sicher zu
stellen dass moldawien eine pro
russische regierung bekommt sie streben
einen regime wechsel an sie könnten zb
der metro droht das land mit raketen
anzugreifen oder die regierung mit
gewalt entfernen entweder mit den
interessen stationierten truppen
zusammen mit luft land einheiten als
verstärkung oder gar auf direktem wege
falls sie doch noch in der ukraine
erfolg haben sollten so wird entfernt
dies auch heute erscheinen mag das wäre
die gewaltsame lösung aber diese hat
moskau noch gar nicht nötig hat ist doch
noch genügend strategien zur
wirtschaftlichen kriegsführung in seinem
köcher russland könnte einen wahren
ökonomischen orkan auf moldawien
loslassen denn die wahrheit ist dass die
schlinge moskaus fest um den heiß der
moldauischen wirtschaft gewickelt ist
einerseits kommt fast das gesamte gas
auf das moldawien angewiesen ist um
seine bescheidene industrie zu betreiben
und um zu heizen aus ihr habt wohl
erraten aus russland und ja wir reden
über ein land in dem es im winter
bitterkalt werden kann ähnlich verhält
es sich natürlich mit erdöl und außerdem
führen die wichtigsten teilbilanz durch
das separatistische transnistrien die
gefahr wäre also mehr als realistisch
und in der tat müssen wir gar nicht so
weit ausholen moskau hat diese waffe
erst vor kurzem zu seinem politischen
vorteil eingesetzt so warm oder oktober
2021 gezwungen den notstand auszurufen
nachdem gazprom die lieferungen um ein
drittel gekürzt und verlangt hatte dass
moldawien mehr als das doppelte des
bisherigen preises zahlt um den gasfluss
aufrechtzuerhalten nun wird natürlich
der eine oder andere einwendung das gas
kommt auch ein wirtschaftsunternehmen
sei und eben seine gewinne maximieren
wolle dabei wirkten harte
preisverhandlungen eben dazu aber nichts
könnte von der realität weiter entfernt
sein bei gazprom rasiert und all den
anderen russischen rohstoffunternehmen
geht es nur am rande ums geldverdienen
in wahrheit handelt es sich bei diesen
organisationen um die ökonomischen
waffen des kreml an allen schaltstellen
sitzen von putin handverlesene
geheimdienstleute die rein gar nichts
von betriebswirtschaft verstehen dafür
aber sehr viel von politik und davon wie
man machtstrukturen kontrolliert diesen
unternehmen ging es nie darum optimal zu
wirtschaften und so ihre gewinne zu
maximieren wie sonst könnte man erklären
dass zum beispiel am jahresende gazprom
sein gas am pol für rund 850 dollar
verkaufte an weißrussland jedoch gerade
mal für 30 dollar es liegt sicher nicht
an der entfernung oder an den kosten für
den transport des gases denn diese sind
beide fällen praktisch identisch es geht
schlicht und einfach um erpressung
politische gefälligkeiten nach dem motto
wenn eure regierung nach unserer pfeife
tanzt würden sie einer volkswirtschaft
vorerst nicht ab und genau so sprang
moskau auch mit china um entweder wir
ruinieren dich oder du akzeptierst eine
neue politische vereinbarung
gazprom will darin einen neuen gas viel
an wenn es im gegenzug seine bindungen
an die eu schwächt der russische konzern
wird beschuldigt die energiekrise zu
nutzen um die neue prowestliche
regierung zu bestrafen wenn die republik
moldau zu stellen würde ihr
freihandelsabkommen mit der eu zu ändern
und die anwendung der eu vorschriften zu
verzögern dann und nur dann bekäme sie
ausreichend günstiges gas am ende
scheint es so haben sie sich hierbei
irgendwo auf halbem wege getroffen
moldawien bekam gas und russland
politische zugeständnisse aber das ist
noch nicht alles etwa 80 prozent des
stroms in moldawien wird von kraftwerken
in der abtrünnigen republik
transnistrien erzeugt zum großteil noch
ein erbe das verzeiht der russische
stromversorger hat die preis erheblich
erhöht und zwingt chisinau dazu
lieferverträge immer nur für sehr kurze
zeiträume abzuschließen wenn also am
ende des monats der strom vertrag nicht
verlängert oder die gasversorgung
unterbrochen wird könnte das debakel für
moldawien mehr als beträchtlich sein
[Musik]
moldawien versucht diese situation durch
den bau von stromleitungen nach rumänien
zu verwenden aber es wird jahre dauern
bis diese fertig sind die prorussischen
regierungen haben diese vorhaben nämlich
immer wieder hintertrieben um die
abhängigkeit moldawiens von den
machthabern in kreml zu erhöhen auch
moldawien wurde perfekt schröder riesig
aber das ist immer noch nicht alles fast
schon verzweifelt hat der minister für
infrastruktur und regionale entwicklung
angedeutet es ist land erwägt strom aus
der ukraine zu kaufen aber ist es
realistisch sich auf ein land zu
verlassen das sich im krieg befindet
schwer bombardiert wird energie freiheit
und unabhängigkeit haben für uns einen
preis und nach dem beginn des krieges in
der ukraine haben wir keine andere wahl
als diesen preis der unabhängigkeit zu
zahlen andres pino moldawiens minister
für infrastruktur und entwicklung
natürlich denkt moskau dass all diese
probleme die pro europäische regierung
irgendwann zermürben die moldauer dazu
bringen werden wieder in den sturm mit
solchen russland zurück zu kehren und
passt jetzt gut auf denn eine von
estland erst im jahr 2022 veröffentlicht
der geheimdienst auswertung ist sehr
deutlich darauf hin dass der kreml
bereits aktiv daran arbeitet die
derzeitige proeuropäische regierung zu
stürzen diesen bericht zufolge würde
moskau gerade die energieabhängigkeit
den einfluss der orthodoxen kirche die
von putins geheimdienst fsb vollkommen
unterwandert und gleichgeschaltet wurde
und das russischsprachige fernsehen als
waffe einzusetzen
und wisst ihr was die wahrheit ist dass
die präsidenten selbst kaum zweifel
daran hegt dass sich das politische
klima genau in diese richtung entwickelt
russische politische kräfte in moldawien
haben bereits von massenprotesten
gesprochen und die regierung zum
rücktritt und zur abhaltung vorgezogener
parlamentswahlen aufgefordert damit sie
der regierung die schuld für
wirtschaftliche schwierigkeiten und hohe
energiepreise geben können meinte
präsidentin moldawiens liebe visual
voltage zuschauer moldawien macht gerade
eine sehr schwere zeit durch zu den
steigenden gas und strompreisen kommen
noch die realen auswirkungen des krieges
zum beispiel haben dort innerhalb eines
monats etwa 100.000 ukrainische
flüchtlinge zuflucht gefunden eine
riesige zahl und eine herkulesaufgabe
für ein so kleines land im vergleich
bezogen auf die einwohnerzahl ist das so
als wären 3,2 millionen flüchtlinge auf
einmal nach deutschland gekommen
außerdem sind etwa 14 prozent der
moldauischen exportwirtschaft die ihre
waren in die ukraine weißrussland und
russland verkauft fast vollständig zum
erliegen gekommen die inflation ist
aufgrund der höheren energiekosten und
der verteuerung importe durch die
unterbrechung des verkehrs im hafen
wurden und deshalb auf 22 prozent
gestiegen denn auch deshalb ist der
wichtigste hafen für den moldauischen
handel vergesst nicht dass wir hier über
einen binden ansprechen
[Musik]
erschwerend kommt hinzu dass die
überweisungen von auslands moldauern
ausdrücklich ländern ebenfalls stark
rückläufig sind denn allein auf russland
entfallen mehr als zehn prozent aller
einnahmen die moldawien auf diese weise
erzielt dh der kreml könnte versucht
sein das leben in moldau durch proteste
auf den straßen transnistriens
gaslieferstopps blick aus oder gar der
androhung militärischer maßnahmen weiter
zu erschweren ihr wisst schon angeblich
nur um die russischsprachige bevölkerung
vor den bösen nazis zu beschützen die
vielleicht beste nachricht für moldawien
war daher bisher wie schlecht die dinge
für das russische militär in der ukraine
laufen aber eine überlebensgarantie ist
dies für sie auch nicht denn gerade
jetzt erhöht sich die schlagzahl der
konflikt ereignisse im eiltempo die
debatte darüber ob die republik moldau
ihre neutralität aufgegeben wurden sich
der nato annähern sollte verschärft sich
zunehmend
die britische außenministerin list rus
hatte am zwanzigsten mal erklärt dass
die republik moldau nach nato standard
ausgerüstet werden sollte um sich gegen
die gefahr einer russischen invasion zu
schützen und nur wenige tage später
wurde der ehemalige pro-russische
moldawische präsident egon bode nach
einer reihe von razzien im rahmen einer
gerichtlichen untersuchung wegen des
verdachts auf hochverrat korruption
illegale bereicherung und illegaler
parteifinanzierung
verhaftet der druck in den adern auf
wladimir putins stören dürfte damit den
im marianengraben bereits weit hinter
sich gelassen haben wie lange wird der
kreml herrscher also noch tatenlos
zusehen nun wir bleiben am ball aber bis
dahin seit erst mal an der reihe glaubt
ihr dass putin in nächster zeit
versuchen wird die moldawische regierung
zu stürzen oder hat er jetzt einfach
schon genug um die ohren oder könnte
transnistriens vielleicht doch einer
seiner joker sein mit dem er versucht
das blatt in der ukraine von der anderen
seite her zu wenden wie immer sind wir
schon auf eure beiträge im
kommentarbereich gespannt ich hoffe dass
euch dieses video gefallen hat mir
vielleicht auch dass er gelernt habt
falls ja gibt es bei den leitenden
freund und vergess ich das auto mit
glöckchen um keines unserer videos mehr
so verpassen natürlich freuen uns auf
die das hat über eine spende von euch
und james hält dies bringt und
weiterzuführen dazu findet ihr eine
beschreibung unter dem video mach's gut
und bis 1
[Musik]